ROUSSEL TO TIE H
JENIK STAYS STRONG ON THE PUCK.!
AND THE FIRST SHOT ON SLOT OF A
SAIL PAST A BEWILDERED
ROBERTSON.
TAKES THECROSS
TO TYLER SEGUIN WHO HAD COME IN
FIRST PERIOD FOR HIM.
GA
HERE IS SEGUIN, ALREADY A OUTER
MARKS AND
HEISKANEN
ONE-TIMER
SCORE!
FOR THIS ONE.
PERFECT CLIP OFF THE TOP OF
HEISKANEN FINDS LINDELL, BACK T.
AND THE REBOUNDN
TWO OFIEF
APPEARANCES F USUALLY SEE GUYS
OUT THE DRAFT AT 21 YEARS OLD.
BENN.
STRALMAN CUTTING
THE STARS ZONE AND POP A
>> Josh: 235I6S TO THE LE
PUCK.
- IT GOES OFF OF ROBERTSON AND .
DEFLECTED.
NO ICING.
TEN MINUTES.N
FRONT, THEY SCOOOORE!  THE BACK
FROM PHIL KESSEL.
SURVEYING HIS
ICE.
O'BRIEN TRIED TO SLICE THROUGH .
PUCK IS DROPPED.
IT'S BACK TO THE POINT. THREE-OE
OVERTIME.
>> Josh: HINTZ,
TRAVIS BOYD.
THE COYOTES COME ALL THEHE